would you dare bring extreme sports to
the next level do a bungee jump with no
strings attached
for it we won't let you hit the ground
we'll use science to catch you with some
big magnets how would it work
how many magnets would you need and what
are the chances that this could end up
badly for you this is what if and here's
what would happen if you did a wireless
bungee jump with magnets you've probably
seen these thrill-seekers jumping off
cliffs and bridges but they're extreme
doesn't come close to what we have in
mind
bungee jumping usually means that you're
attached to an elastic rope you're also
secured by a harness and protected from
colliding with the bungee cord by soft
padding what we propose is a bungee jump
- the rope plus a couple of massive
magnets could it work theoretically this
could be possible magnets have north and
south poles and they produce magnetic
fields around them the opposite poles
are attracted to each other and the
similar poles produce a force of
repulsion what you'd need for a wireless
bungee jump is a magnet strapped to your
harness with its south pole facing
downwards you'd need another magnet on
the ground with its South Pole facing
upwards you'd also need to think hard
before you agree to do this because I
wouldn't recommend trying it at home one
thing I would recommend is to learn more
about magnets among other things with
our friends at brilliant the sponsor of
this episode I never thought doing math
could be fun but brilliant totally
changed my mind if you've ever felt like
taking a deep dive into the world of
math fundamentals but we're afraid of
long formulas and big
birds like me well you should check out
brilliant I went to brilliant to see
what they had on magnets and I ended up
learning a whole lot more about
axe-throwing gymnastics and my fridge
you should try to go to brilliant org
slash what if to sign up for free oh and
also the first 200 people who go to that
link will get 20% off the annual premium
subscription for more interactive
courses daily challenges and quizzes now
that you're all geared up you're ready
to take the jump the reason why bungee
jumpers aren't splashed all over the
ground after the jump is that the
elastic rope slows them down to a stop
and then pulls them back up then down
then up then down then up until all the
energy from the jump is spent with
magnets it's a little trickier
when you're in freefall the
gravitational force pulls you down and
increases your speed by 9.8 meters per
second every second that you fall after
3 seconds of freefall you'd reach a
speed of almost 30 meters per second
believe you wouldn't have a stretchy
rope to soften your claw here's the
thing about magnets when they're apart
from each other they're repulsive force
is close to zero but as they get closer
together the repulsive force increases
very rapidly as you jumps down the
magnets would stop you just a few
centimeters from the ground but because
of the forces involved in stopping you
so fast you feel as if your body got
smashed by a drug I know I promised you
wouldn't get squashed into the ground
but I didn't say you wouldn't get
crushed by the repulsive force between
two magnets if you're wondering if this
could get any worse
but it could if you move slightly out of
line during your fall you'd risk
flipping together with the magnet
attached to you now instead of facing
the opposite poles to each other
the magnets would be facing the same
poles and what do magnets do when they
face similar poles yeah they attract
nothing will stop the magnets from
touching each other not even your body
caught in between the jump with magnets
was a bad idea
sorry about that looks like falling from
an airplane could be safer than that
under the right conditions but that's a
story for another
[Music]